in this video we'll talk about the
satellite DNA satellite DNA are
repetitive DNA consisting of short
sequences which are repeated several
times
now it carries variable 80 Rich repeat
units known as repeat monomers and they
can form an array which can totally
range up to 100 megabase pairs
the monomod length of these repeat units
could vary from 150 to 400 base pairs on
average but they could be as short as
like 15 or even like three four base
pairs and this is present in both
animals and implants
now this satellite DNA was first
characterized from an Ulta
centrifugation reaction so in this
cesium chloride density gradient
centrifugation the main genomic DNA
forms a thick band at a specific buoyant
density but a small band was observed at
a at the lighter side and this band is
known as that satellite band so if we
plot that data for in an absorbance
versus density graph one can understand
the main band is there in a thick
position having a buoyant density around
1.7
whereas the satellite band has a buoyant
density lesser than that it's lighter in
uh buoying density
so this satellite DNA is very
interesting but how they are different
compared to other average DNA sequence
so obviously we can understand they have
lesser buoyant density
and this lesser Point density can
actually
occur from
difference in the GC content they have
much less GC content than the average of
the genome and that can be calculated
using this particular formula
now let's talk more about the satellite
DNA so where can we find the satellite
DNA in our genome or in the chromosome
they can be found in different regions
they can be found in let's say telomeres
and centromeres but they could be also
interspersed in the chromosome
so what are the features of the
satellite DNA obviously as we mentioned
they are highly repetitive tandemically
repeated and they have array of repeats
in a genome
so overall they are 80 Rich that we have
already talked about now let's talk
about several subtypes of satellite DNA
there could be Alpha satellites beta
satellites microsatellites and mini
satellites all of these different
categories are classified according to
their repeat unit length and where they
can found what they are found actually
so for example Alpha satellites are
highly enriched in the centromeric
region they have a repeat unit of 171
base pairs beta satellites are found in
pericentric region they have a repeat
unit of approximately 68 to 70 base
pairs
now microsatellites are very small
repeat units which have repeated units
from 2 to 10 base pairs and they are
dispersed throughout the chromosome
in contrast there are many satellites
which are enriched in telomere and
subtelomeric regions their rapid unit
ranges from 10 to 100 base pairs
so there are different categories of
these signals and they are quite diverse
so in general these repeat sequences has
very high mutation rate for example
microsatellites especially has very high
mutation rate compared to other coding
regions
and this High mutation rate is due to a
phenomena known as the replication fork
slippage
so replication enzymes fall down in that
particular repetitive region and there
are high chances that wrong base pairs
are Incorporated in that particular
sequence regions
most likely these repetitive DNA
sequences are found in
heterochromatinized structures
like centromias like pericentric regions
and generally they are not transcribed
but they have a lot of significance in
terms of
forensic significance because each of
the individual has different number of
tandem repeats so let's say we talk
about this particular agat units in one
individual it can have seven repeats in
other individual there might be four or
let's say 12 repeats so these repeats
are very different between individual
and this principle or this polymorphism
principle is used in the forensic system
so let's say there is a crime scene and
there are two suspect suspect one has
the chromosomal configuration like this
and the suspect 2 has the overall
repetitive units like this
now when the repetitive units are
actually PCR Amplified and compared
between suspect and the crime scenes one
can quickly understand
who is this aspect among these two
and this is due to high polymorphism
between these short repeating units so
that is why from an forensic point of
view these repetitive DNA sequence are
pretty important
you can get more notes and flashcards in
my Facebook page you can also follow us
on Instagram page you can support our
Channel by super thanks option
see you in next video